happy Saturday reject nation it's Greg
Alba here today we're gonna check out
Star Wars the last Jedi heroes trailer
uploaded from the official Star Wars
channel so I figure this must be worth
check it out I already have my tickets
for Star Wars less Jedi on Thursday
night and then Friday the next morning's
I'm gonna watch this twice baby I can't
wait before we watch this
I wanted to given mention to the
Stardust app that we have been actively
using and the community's been going
over there so thank you to everyone for
helping us pass the thousand followers
this app is great it allows you to do
30-second reactions for a new film TV
show or trailer wanted to mention it
again because right now John and I were
watching The Punisher over the next few
days we're posting quick reactions for
every episode and then we'll do a full
series review on this channel but if you
want to stay up to date with our quick
pinkness in each episode follow us there
and there'll be more posts outside of
that on the stardust app so follow us
there peeps last Jedi
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
50 god the visuals just looks so freakin
good in this movie man they look so good
this was like more of a fydd trailer
than it was a ray or Luke trailer this
time around a time we get some footage
it's really capitalizing on Finn is that
first shot that they show like when Finn
is officially was that him officially
waking up I really do love that line
when poke comes up to him you must have
a thousand questions and immediately
Finn's just asking where's ray that
strong level of concern a companionship
something tells me that this is gonna be
a grant story but very centrally focused
and contained within its characters just
something as little as that gives me a
hint into that idea
that this is gonna be a very
character-driven action-packed adventure
in the Star Wars world which just makes
it better than anything else and they're
calling this trailer Heroes remember
Justice League had a heroes trailer
about a month ago and that was the vibe
I really got a heroic vibe the heroic
tale you know a lot of these last Jedi
trailers are really in the mystery the
intrigue is ray going dark this trailer
was really honing in on Finn having that
heroic touch and I felt motivated it was
like yeah let's fight it it's really
love that Finn's first thought when he
wakes up as where's ray so I feel like
there's gonna be a very specific theme
and story going on with ray and Luke and
the journey she's on and kylo and I feel
like the true heroic vibes will be
coming in from Finn and Poe oh my god I
I cannot all right guys well you can
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell make sure
to download and follow us on the
stardust app check out our patreon
become a patron i ejected a lot of fun
perks over there post daily content so
check it out when you can